so as we continue our discussions on DC
rebirth something that I want to point
out here is again going through and
looking it is you know looking at what
it is you guys like and what you don't
like
I've actually updated this schedule I
would you all again find down in the
description something to keep in mind is
that this is kind of tentative until we
finally settle on something that really
seems to work but what we do here is we
pick up with the second story arc of the
Superman solo series which again focuses
largely on Superman and his son and this
is one of the really cool things that I
like about what we're getting with this
Superman line of publications under a
Peter Tomasi what it basically does here
is he just again emphasizes Superboy and
Superman now for those of you guys who
are new to DC we birth this is the crux
of things as they seem to exist way way
back when when you had the old school DC
Comics you know really before crisis on
Infinite Earths the way it was set up is
you had Superman stories which focus on
himself and then you had the Action
Comics line of stories which focused on
Superman in addition to his supporting
cast but as the years progressed as the
crisis on Infinite Earths event happened
and as we started moving from 1985
really up and going into the new 52 the
actually colleagues and Superman line of
stories began to merge in the sense that
they were usually telling two sides of
the same story where sometimes it was
just the same story stretched over both
line of publications but with DC Weber
that looks like DC's going back to the
way things used to be in the sense that
Action Comics tells one line of stories
and Superman tells another and so with
this son I guess the Oh Superboy son of
Superman situation we pick up with
Jonathan Kent working on a science
project and this is one of the reasons
why it's so cool is because we really
get this homegrown feel to the Superman
line of stories you really get this this
feeling that we're getting a bit of
behind the scenes you know we're getting
a feeling like what goes on in the life
of Superman when he's not out dealing
with superheroes and I'm sure that's
exactly what this is meant to be now the
project as it's being worked on by
Jonathan seems to be some kind of
electronic device or some kind of a
teleportation device and my initial
thought was that he was creating a
mother box but that doesn't seem to be
the case instead it seems as though he's
just creating a technological device
using his knowledge of a Kryptonian
artifacts Kryptonian history and so on
and the box ends up actually teleporting
to the various Kryptonian crystals now
the reason why this happens is the
as there within the fortress of solitude
and this is one of the other cool things
too is we get this really cool unspoken
dichotomy right you know where we have
the life of Superman when he's working
on scientific stuff with the Sun that
doesn't happen in the house you know
it's almost the Superman equivalent to
don't play baseball in the house play
baseball outside you know don't work on
your kryptonian stuff in the house work
on your component stuff in the fortress
of solitude not only that I think this
really gives the son of Superman kind of
a place to understand his heritage
because this is really a big question
when I initially picked up the comic is
how much emphasis is going to be placed
on Jonathan Kent learning about the
history of his family learning about the
history of the house of El and so it
seems to be that even if we don't see it
in the pages even if it's happening off
panel that Superman is teaching a Sunday
history of Kryptonians as best he can
and so what happens is that when this
device touches the Kryptonian artifacts
it activates and it teleports a neo
Superman and his son to an island now
this is one of the really cool things
that DC we Werth is doing because as we
know DC rebirth is designed to combine
the pre new 52 and the new 52
continuities but there were a lot of
things that were done pre new 50 Q that
were out of continuity they were just
stories that existed out there they were
largely considered to be Elseworlds but
not every time were they branded else
walls instead they were just stories
that was they're a perfect example of
this is a DC line of publications it was
a six issue limited series I think in
2003 2004 and it was called DC the new
frontier now those of you guys who read
those line of stories I'm sure you're
nodding your head and you're saying oh
thank god because DC new frontier was a
really really good line of stories and
we'll get more into that as we go
through this video but with their
immediate arrival of course the question
is where are they now this is one of the
cool things here because with Superman
we expect fearlessness right you know we
expect the Superman that we all know and
love to say okay I'm in a strange
situation the worst thing I can do is
panic especially considering the fact
that he has his son with him and that's
why I like this so much because for
Jonathan Kent and this is actually
something that we're gonna focus on here
in a little while he's still just a boy
and it's very easy for Superman to lose
track of the fact that his son is just a
boy now in truth despite being just a
boy he's still formidable in his own
right I mean he's extremely durable he
may not necessarily be on the same
as his father but Jonathan Kent is not
someone that you just run up and take a
wallet from he's not a kid you just run
up in mug you know he has a hold the
whole range you know the whole gamut of
abilities that his father has but being
on this island being in this location
because they don't really know what's
going on the initial idea is to try to
grab their bearings now the other cool
thing about this is that as we know with
a pre new 52 Superman it's always
important to preserve life as best he
can this is really kind of cornerstone
of who he was as a person that you know
all life is precious and of course this
creates a whole nother slew of
philosophical arguments but the fact
remains here that according to Superman
you should always preserve life as best
you can
regardless of what that life is and so
when both Jonathan and Superman are set
upon by a giant fish Superman could very
easily just destroy this thing but once
he's on the inside of it he realizes
this thing has a beating heart you know
this thing has his life you know it is
it is alive in some form of fashion and
so Superman effectively just escapes
from it you know without ever really
having to kill it now when they take off
or when they when they leave they
immediately go to the island itself and
they stumble upon what appear to be some
various world war two artifacts
including a downed plane different
things like this and this is one of the
other cool things is Superman gives us
son a lot of history here in terms of in
terms of history of the of the world
history of different wartime conflicts
things like that and again this is when
we start delving into the realm of new
frontier now we weren't told this you
know it wasn't as though you know Tomasi
just plastered you know giant red
letters over the screen and said and
suddenly were in the new frontier
universe instead it was just a gradual
introduction we were just kind of left
to believe that they were transported to
an island somewhere but Tomasi also
takes the next step in telling us that
you know the most logical scenario for
us as readers would be well I mean if
they can fly why don't they just fly
away from the island back to you know
the fortress of solitude or back to
Superman's home with Lois Lane but when
they take off and they start you know
flying the issue they run into is
there's this massive fog that's
surrounding the entire area and they
can't seem to get past it now we'll talk
up a little more about this fog here in
a second once we actually start getting
into the revelation of this being the
new frontier universe but I feel like
Tomas is taking a step with this fog to
have it represent something as you know
akin to a barrier so to speak but the
fact remains here that as they're trying
to make their escape as they're trying
to get away again they're suddenly set
upon by pterodactyls these are
massive beasts of huge proportions and
this is also one of the interesting
things because viola Tomasi kind of
leaves it to us to say you know is this
an accurate portrayal of dinosaurs would
we expect to actually see pterodactyls
of this size in the end it's not a huge
thing it's really just kind of fun to
see Superman and his son fighting
against dinosaurs not only that in the
midst of the onslaught crypto is
actually eaten or at least swallowed by
one of these dinosaurs and I'll be 100%
honest with you guys when I saw that I
was so immersed in the stories I was
reading it when I saw that I was like oh
my god crypto I can't believe that and
then I had to pet max you know to make
myself feel better but it was you know
of course we know crypto being a super
dog is easily able to make his escape
away from from this particular creature
which again they basically just take off
and this is an on running theme with
with Tomasi he maintains the notion of
everything you know everything surviving
and or at least seeming to survive and
the reason why is because when it comes
to this line of publications when it
comes to the Superman and son line of
stories and the Superman line of comics
these are not - not designed to be hard
and gritty you know it's not as though
you're gonna have Superman and Jonathan
Kent fighting off against slavers you're
not going to see something like that
these are designed to be more upbeat
they're designed to be more fun they're
designed to be you know fluff pieces in
a lot of ways as opposed to action
comics which might deal a little bit
more with some dark and gritty stuff but
the other half of this is that the
Superman himself isn't really meant to
be dark and greedy that's one of the
reasons why new 52 Superman wasn't
really considered to be such a great
great piece of writing that's one of the
reasons why a lot of traditional
Superman fans didn't like him because
there was enough dark and gritty stuff
going on in DC Comics he had the Green
Lantern mythos we have the Sinestro
Corps taking over you know during the
events of edge of oblivion you have the
Batman line of publications Detective
Comics he got Nightwing you have all
these different publications that can
give you dark and gritty stuff Superman
in college you're supposed to be hopeful
and fun and that really seems to be what
Tomas is grabbing from us but as we go
through with a Superman and Superboy
again you're discovering more of these
these different foundations what really
appears to be kind of a world war 2
bunker style situation where there's you
know machine guns and there's a you know
barbed wire and so on
they eventually go into one of these
bunkers and they come across a wall that
says this is the story of the loser
now this is where we started to get into
new frontier stuff and the reason why I
say that is new frontier was a lot of
publications that was designed to bridge
the gap between the Golden Age and the
Silver Age and the reason why I say that
is in DC comics there wasn't really any
indication of there being a clear-cut
line between the Golden Age and the
Silver Age instead back in the 1950s
when the Silver Age officially started
with the introduction of Barry Allen it
was just kind of this merging it was
just kind of this blurry line you know
the the story the I guess the you know
the origins of Superman from the Golden
Age continued on the origins of Wonder
Woman Aquaman Batman so on and so forth
from that era continued on the whole
reason why we got the Silver Age whole
reason why we got earth-1 was because
the introduction of Barry Allen and Hal
Jordan coincided with the vanishing of
the original flash Jay Garrick and the
original Green Lantern Allen Scott and
so fans were quite literally confused I
didn't really know what was going on the
question they had is if Superman Batman
Wonder Woman Aquaman you know if those
characters are still the same then why
are you know why do we have Barry Allen
why do we have Hal Jordan what happened
to Jay Garrick and what happened to
Allen Scott and so what this did is it
again allow DC to basically create their
multiverse going forward but provide new
origins but there was still a lot of
stuff that wasn't really covered there
of course we knew that superheroes are
really popular during World War Two
within the line of publications within
the line of comics we saw a lot of
stories that were that dealt with World
War two Superman in the various
superheroes fighting against the Axis
powers even though those leaders you
know Mussolini Hitler Hirohito they were
never really mentioned by name but the
fact remains here that during this
during this time actually was really
going into the late 1960s and early
1970s DC was still trying to tap into
the the war market just because of the
fact that there was still some interest
even if it was falling away you know for
the whole World War two you know Cold
War era line of stories and so the
losers were originally introduced to
feed into this to basically give us as
the reader during the late 60s and early
70s a depiction of you know different
people fighting during World War two the
problem with this was that over the
years the losers started to receive a
lot of retcons retroactive continuities
those of you guys who don't know whet
row active continuity is when a writer
goes in and changes the past of
something there were a lot of retcons
with the losers there were a lot of in
continuity explanations that didn't make
sense with what previously happened but
DC new frontier again kind of bridged
this gap and what DC new frontier did is
came back and told us here's what was
going on with superheroes between the
Silver Age and the Golden Age the issue
with this is that it eventually fell out
of continuity and it got to the point
where it was referred to as earth 21 it
was his own you know separate universe
where John F Kennedy had never been
assassinated
you know superheroes were you were a
little fearful of superheroes early on
but then they started to embrace the
idea of superheroes you know and it
really changed things up but the losers
during this line of stories um were
again you know there were American
soldiers that were fighting during World
War two and they were basically stuck on
dinosaur island and over the course of
their their stories they had basically
been killed off one by one until this
guy you know a captain storm was the
only guy left and so what uh what
happens here is Tomas he basically
brings captain storm back and he seems
to be the last survivor of the losers
during the whole experience with you
know on dinosaur island and this is why
I say he was starting to tap in a new
frontier because I'd really gotten over
earlier but if you guys were you know
looking at the helices we were going
through it we had seen an instance where
we had it you know basically there was a
dog tag belonging to a guy named John
collee and John cloud was a member of
the losers I think it was actually the
leader or the second-in-command or
something along those lines my knowledge
on the losers team isn't wildly huge but
it's enough that I can offer some
explanation on the team but you know
with with with Captain storm making his
appearance here one of the funny things
in the situation he doesn't recognize
who Superman is now this is where things
seem to get a little hairy because of
the fact that Superman was around during
this time period
you know when Captain storm was active
so the question is why doesn't captain
still remember who he is but it's really
not a huge point I mean in truth unless
you were somebody who's knowledgeable
about comics you know during what during
the World War 2 era you know unless
you've gone through and you know done a
whole writing segment on the history of
Superman it wouldn't really occur to you
to ask that question but with them
arriving here you know of course the
question is where did you come from why
are you here you know and Superman and
his son are just as curious about you
know Captain storm as he is about them
and basically Captain storm just runs
over the story that I just gave you guys
you know essentially saying that he and
his team ended up on dinosaur island
they were all being killed off one by
one you know and so the question that I
guess the goal of the Superman basically
has this twofold
the first is paying respect to the
legacy of the losers and the second is
to to get off the island now the way he
pays respect here is actually really
really cool you know for Captain storm
because he's been living day
by day somebody just trying to survive
he hasn't really had the chance to give
his you know give his dead friends the
kind of burial that he thinks they
deserve and so Superman offers him this
opportunity he basically takes the
bodies of these different people and
starts burying them you know so that
happens storm can effectively send off
you know to those individuals that he
fought against to those Friends of the
Hat but after this is done because of
the fact that captain storm has been on
this island for so long Superman and his
son they should we say here's the
artifact that we're looking for here's
the device have you seen it and he says
yes but the problem with this is that
it's most likely been taken by you know
him or the person or the individual or
being or whatever it is that's basically
residing over this island which
interestingly enough this seems to be
kind of like a combination with King
Kong but touching back on the idea of a
Superman forgetting about the fact that
his son is so young that he's just 10
years old this really hits home when it
seems to impact Superboy and he doesn't
seem to believe that they're gonna make
it home he asked the question you know
what happens if we never get home and
this is why I say this is so cool
because Superman sits down and he says
you know yes you were boy you act so
strong you act so confident and
sometimes I forget you're only 10 years
old and this is such a beautiful piece
of writing because this is Peter Tomasi
telling us that he is just a boy he's
extremely capable he's very strong he
hasn't quite figured out how to fly yet
neo but he is probably going to be every
ounce the man that his father is but at
this point right now he's a kid who
thinks that he won't be able to get home
and he won't see his mom again and it's
so cool because you know it really tells
us that under all the powers and under
all the abilities he's just a kid and so
again you know because of because of the
fact that Superman you know tells his
son yes we're gonna make it home you
know because he plays the Superman role
in saying we will get you back in one
piece
Superman basically creates a wooden leg
for Captain storm so that they can make
their way you know through the jungle in
order to locate this box now their
journey eventually brings them deeper
into the forest and what seems to be the
middle of the forest and they eventually
come across a gorilla now for those of
you guys out there who are well-versed
in DC Comics probably more than I am
if you know whether or not this gorilla
is an actual character from you know
years past in DC feel free to throw it
down in the in the comment section to
say hey that's like this is I'm pretty
sure it's not Grodd you know but to say
hey this is this gorilla has a name and
here's what it is feel free to say that
you know because I I'm not knowledgeable
enough to know
you know whether or not this is just a
character thrown in for the sake of the
story or if this gorilla has a long
running history in DC but again you know
because of the fact that this grill it
seems to have absolute power here
because it seems to be the only real
intelligent organism it's more or less
fashioned and Armie for itself using all
the different creatures that exist on
this planet they are on this island
moreso than that it also has the device
that Superman and his son are looking
for now what's also kind of cool here is
that you know Superman basically tutors
a son you know a little more in the use
of his powers and that's one of the
reasons why this is cool is because you
know we would think or at least it would
seem that if Superman were going to
train his son in powers he would take
him to a feel that he made or some huge
empty area and the fortress of solitude
and say now just shoot your heat vision
and keep shooting it until you do
whatever it is you need to do or until
you have full control but instead he
basically takes them out of the field
and says you know use your vision when
you need to you know use your strength
when you need to you know hold on to me
because you can't quite fly yet but the
idea is that they basically fend off the
forces of this gorilla and in the
conflict they snatch the a device out of
the eye of the gorilla now that's also
kind of messed up too when you think
about it that they literally snatch the
device out of the gorillas eye but
what's also cool here is that this this
artifact seems to be the same artifact
that was contained within the eye of the
octopus that they fought during the son
of Superman's story that the first story
arc which you can find down in the
description but the fact remains that
once they were able to once were able to
grab this device and they're able to
teleport away the initial idea is that
maybe captain storm will join them but
instead he says no he says he's going to
stay here and he's going to fight to
death with his friends even if that's
what it takes and so he basically stays
behind and Superman and his son make it
back to the forces of solitaire now the
issue with this is we don't quite know
exactly how this happens you know this
this this gap isn't really being bridged
by by Tomasi at all but he tells us or
he shows us anyway that there is of
course this giant octopus with the eye
that there is someone in possession of
captain storms peg leg and that you know
they have this artifact that belonged to
this octopus or seems to belong to this
octopus and they're simply watching
everything unfold but with that being
said we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it hopefully you guys in here
and he's scraping in the background but
if you did max was eating stuff
anyway if you guys are new here to the
Rob poor feel free to hit the subscribe
button you know join the Rob port if you
guys want to see more Superman stuff
make sure you guys drop a like and yeah
let me know down in the comments section
what you guys thought about this video
and I will catch you guys later peace
[Music]